[Music]
well more than 2 300 nevadans will be
diagnosed with breast cancer this year
but a new test could dramatically
shorten their treatment
and could revolutionize cancer treatment
worldwide
the theralink test is designed to map
out the exact
treatment needed to fight a specific
type of cancer it's really
groundbreaking stuff
and it's being tested right here in
southern nevada here's today's health
watch
i think this would just answer a lot of
my
questions and my doubts staring down
cancer can give anyone pause
anika vallejo is a mother of three and a
stage one breast cancer patient
she's agreed to a groundbreaking new
test being conducted at comprehensive
cancer centers
she's the first in the world to receive
theralink
it's not often in las vegas that we get
the opportunity to be the first in
anything
and so she is really the first patient
to receive this test
the molecular test analyzes various
proteins on a cancerous cell
and then determines which proteins are
turned on or
off this is part of something called
precision oncology
and what precision oncology does is
we're trying to find the right p
with the right drug for the right
patient at the right time
now typically oncologists prescribe a
first line of treatment
if that doesn't work then a second line
and eventually a third
no matter what kind of treatment you get
just always kind of wonder
is this the right one should i be really
doing this dr schwartz hopes theralink
will remove a lot of the guesswork
i can see a future in the near future
where
every cancer patient gets this type of
testing molecular testing of the tumor
because it really gives doctors more
information about what the right
treatment is
for patients it could be a path that's
less invasive
and more accurate so we are going to be
following aniko's journey and bring you
updates on her progress